(siren blares)
(phone rings)
(cart wheel squeaking)
(spraying)
(Drips)
(upbeat trancey music)
(air hissing)
(deep inhale)
(heart monitor beeping)
- What's going on?
Was I in another coma?
Hey, who's that fat guy
you're in love with?
- Just stop moving.
Stop moving.
I'm working here. God!
Now I get why George W.
Bush only paints dogs.
Less talk, talk, talk,
move, move, move.
- You want to be more
like George W. Bush?
He's like America's
worst president.
- (chuckles) Not
even close any more.
He's actually pretty beloved.
He's like America's
grandpa right now.
- Bill Cosby is
America's grandpa.
- Not according to the 60
women who accused him of rape!
- What?
- Stop moving!
- 60 women? What the? Oh my God.
Well I hope he
spends time in jail,
like that other rapist Mike
Tyson, that piece of shit!
- Iron Mike's number one!
He had this great Broadway show.
He's a real talent.
He's in the Hangover.
He knocked out the fat guy.
- Mike Tyson?
- Stop moving!
- Next, you're gonna tell
me we love OJ Simpson now.
- We do! We just
let him out of jail.
The Juice is loose. He had
a great year last year.
They shot a show about him,
and won a bunch of Emmys.
Then they shot a documentary
and it won the Oscar.
- An Oscar?
- For documentary.
- What? Johnny Depp
doesn't even have an Oscar.
And no one can say a bad
word about Johnny Depp.
Bad boyfriend, he smokes inside,
he's way older than he
looks, and Mortdecai.
- Mortdecai was bad? What? How?
It costarred Gwyneth Paltrow,
America's friggin' sweetheart!
- Have you even heard of Goop?
- Goop is great!
- Goop is the worst thing
I've ever fucking heard of!
- It has great recipes.
(glass shatters)
(man screams)
- You bastard.
- Shut up. Shut the
fuck up, okay? Shut up!
I just wanna wear
my Aaron Hernandez
jersey it calms me down.
Where is it?
- You mean this? You mean this?
- Why is that all ripped up?
- Because Aaron
Hernandez is a murderer.
- No!
- He murdered a bunch of
people including himself.
- He's dead?
- He's dead!
- He's a family man.
(Nick gasps)
(heart monitor flatlining)
- And he moved too
much. God damn it!
Ruined the frickin' painting.
(inhales deeply)
- Hey guys? Turns
out this country
doesn't like sick people any
more, so you have to leave.
Oh, they're already
dead. Even better.
(door slams)